two deadly three-point shooters for
producing Easterns
nothing there shot clock down to four
five he
maker this guy Klein the unorthodox shot
look at the hitch look at the [ __ ] back
never shoot the gap on the shooter when
you have two screens coming he gave back
two three he just knocked that head
where it's a long race
[Applause]
thing but net Edwards first team all-big
ten two wrong short mapped out the Akita
the park
[Applause]
[Music]
dan kita dat take these gents the time
he floats it up over the outstretched
arms of home this is what you have to
love this is what the tournament is
about
splits it drama pilot the window he
scores
whatta [ __ ] by tied to Rome go but on
the other hand should Rome get him
anywhere he wants to for the flip shot
Ivana the deity tape and huddled inside
the office support longer goes to work
on I for powers its way Dre hunter and
Virginia now in the lead want to come
back down 10 in the first half hitless
Clark's run down and the subsequent pass
to D a keychain
that's it to the final four for the
first time since 1984 the first number
one seed to punch their ticket to
Minneapolis